what if you were dying from
thirst and hunger would you give your
iman up your faith up in order
to survive probably not probably not
because you'd rather die
in hunger and thirst than give up your
religion right this is how much we value
our faith it's priceless brothers and
sisters let me introduce you to norway
this is a european country where the
vast majority of people have become
irreligious there are two 000 muslims of
a population of about 5 million and most
of these 200 000 muslims have no idea
how to explain islam to their non-muslim
friends and neighbors but that needs to
change allah sent his messenger to call
people to eternal success and that is
why muslims in norway are now
establishing a masjid
and dawa center to enhance the norwegian
dawah but they cannot do this alone we
need to support them if you donate to
the scores you will insha allah reap the
rewards of thousands of muslims coming
back to islam and many of those will
become dwight and invite to islam
you will share in the reward for all
those shahadas and good deeds to come in
so click the link and donate now and
share the video for extra reward